نستخدمنا فتره الكورونا
في ما يعرف بالهاوس كيبل ان احنا نعيد
تنظيم البيت من الداخل بيت الوزاره واعاده
السياحه قعدنا استكشاف اتجاهات السياحه
الدوليه لنتعرف على ما هي
متطلباته في مرحله ما بعد كده وبالتالي تم
تقسيم
ساحين الى شرائح حسب الاهتمامات يعني
المنتج المصري مستعد وجاهز لاستقباله وهي
باختصار السياحه العائليه السياحه
الشاطنيه السياحه الثقافيه والسياحه
المغامرات
من تحديات في العالم كله ليست بالنسبه
لمصر وهي ارتفاع سعر الطاقه طبعا واداب
يؤثر سلبا على اسعار الطيران الدولي وبما
انه 90% من السياحه الدوليه الى مصر تاتي
عن طريق الطيران اصبح الامر في تحدي كبير
لانه رفع قيمه الطيران الدولي الجلوس
الدوليه العالميه اثرت بشكل كبير ايضا على
اقتصاديات كثير من الدول الاوروبيه وهي
السوق الرئيسي المصدر للساحه الى مصر
لدينا الكثير من المناطق المؤهله لاستقبال
استثمارات جديده
وخلق منتجات سياحيه جديده ولكن ننظر الى
التوسعات
بالشيء من الحيطه والحذر
ولانه لا نريد ان يكون هناك تدفقات زائده
عن اللزوم وبالتالي بناخدها
بخطوات مدروسه مصر بلد
قديمه جدا
وبالتالي
نعرف ان احنا كل يوم عندنا
استكشافات اثريه جديده في كل مكان في مصر
وبالتالي الاستثمار في هذا الارث تاريخي
الطويل والعريق مهم جدا
[موسيقى]